To start off this course, we'll look at a set of Twinmotion tools that are designed to make your work easier.
Many of those are the types of tools that you would normally spend time building in real-time engines using code,
but here, they are ready to be used right out of the box.
To learn about these tools, you need to fire up Twinmotion.
I am using Community version 2023.2, which was the latest release version at the time I was recording these videos.
You also need to open the project named One Tools that was provided to you.
This project shows the end results of the part 1 portion of this class.
First, we'll look at animators. Zoom in on the doors on the main building's second level.
You can switch camera speeds using the 1 through 6 hotkeys.
The idea is to make these doors open as the camera approaches.
In Unreal Engine, you could write a blueprint to that effect if you know how to code, but here, it is quite a bit easier.
Before you start though, look at the scene graph.
You'll see it's well organized through the use of containers, making things easily sorted and accessible.
Let's stick with that principle and create a new container to store the door animation.
Collapse containers to see better, and then right-click the main scene graph entry and create a new container.
Name it Tools.
With a right-click, make that container active.
Anything you add to the scene now will be part of that container.
Go to the Assets library under Tools, Animators.
Here, you can choose between our Rotation and Translation tools.
Since we're dealing with pivot instead of sliding doors, we'll use rotators.
Here you will find the rotator tool that you need as well as a few samples.
Simply drag the rotator tool and place it in front of the doors in the scene.
Reposition it to where the hinges of the door should be.
If you accidentally click somewhere else, the rotator disappears from the view.
To select it again, you need to do so in the scene graph.
To make the door react to the rotator, you need to make it a child of the tool.
Select the door in the viewport.
Normally, you'd need to drag it from one container to the next in the scene graph, but that's sometimes difficult if there are too many objects listed.
What I find to be a good alternative is to use Cut and Paste.
So with the door selected, press Ctrl-X to cut it to memory, and then press Ctrl-V to paste it back again.
Visually, nothing happens in the viewport, but in the scene graph, the door has now moved to the active container.
All that's left to do is hierarchically link it to the rotator with a click and drag.
The effect is immediate and continuous.
Select the rotator helper in the scene graph.
There are different animation modes to choose from.
You can also control speed and delay.
To make the rotator react to the camera position, set the animation mode to Once, and then activate the Trigger option.
You can adjust the trigger distance or zone, set it to about 400cm or 4m, adjust the angle for the door opening, set it to a positive or negative value to set the door to open to the inside or to the outside.
As an exercise, do the same for the other door.
Let's look at another tool that Twinmotion has to offer.
Section Cubes.
These are found under Tools, Sections.
Drag the Section Cube into the scene.
Move it around to see the effect.
As the name implies, the Section Cube cuts through the geometry to create cross-sections in your project.
You can use Transform Tools to reshape the cube.
You can also invert the operation if you so choose.
You can change the highlight color.
Go ahead and hide the section box before moving on.
Another tool you may find interesting is the Notes tool.
You can add visual notes to the screen which you can potentially use as part of your design review.
The process is very simple, yet again.
From the Assets library, go to Tools, Notes, and drag a note into the scene into a particular spot, let's say the cafe's entrance.
You can control its size, rotate it around, or you may opt to having it always facing the camera.
To control the space between the text box and its node, you can select the child object in the scene graph and move it around.
You can change the color, or alignment, and of course write down a given note.
In my case, I'm shamelessly paraphrasing a famous movie quote.
Experiment by placing a few more notes in the scene.
Just make sure you hide them before moving on.
Another simple but effective tool is the Measure tool.
You'll find it under Tools, Measure.
It's pretty self-explanatory, so we'll only be spending a passing moment on it using it inside the main building.
Drag it into the scene and see how it snaps onto surfaces.
With it, you can easily measure the distance between surfaces, such as between two walls or between two floors.
Constraints are on by default and you can make adjustments to the color, text position, and global scale.
The dimension text is made to follow the camera.
If you're planning to use the same color for many different objects, consider storing the color so you can access it more easily.
This is definitely more of a design review tool than a rendering tool but still quite effective.
Before you move on, hide the Tools container.
There's one more tool we need to mention, Reflection Probes.
Reflection Probes are used to improve the quality of reflections in real-time environments.
However, it's worth noting that Reflection Probes are somewhat old technology and may not be so necessary as we move forward.
Let's see how reflections are currently handled in the scene by looking at the façade of the main building.
You can see the tree reflected in the glass panes but it's blurry and unconvincing.
What's worse is that if you start moving closer to the façade, there comes a point where that reflection disappears.
This coincides with the moment where the tree is outside the bounds of the viewport.
Twinmotion uses a technique called Screen Space Reflection or SSR.
This means that for reflection to take place, the reflected object must be seen in the viewport.
As you can see, it's not an optimal solution in AEC, although you can get away with it in games environments.
Instead, you can use Reflection Probes to remedy that.
You'll find them in the Asset Library under Tools, Reflection Probes.
Reflection Probes capture the environment around them and project it back onto nearby reflective surfaces.
There are two types available, Spheres and Boxes.
Drag a sphere reflection probe close to the curtain wall.
Currently it doesn't have much effect, we are still only seeing the screen space reflections.
You need to adjust the area of influence of the sphere.
Set it to about 8 meters or 800 centimeters.
Now you can see an effect. It's not perfect yet, but it's getting there.
The biggest difference with what we had a moment ago is the fact that if you zoom closer,
you can still see the reflection of the tree even though the tree is not visible in the viewport anymore.
The quality of the reflections is adjustable.
Reflection captures are essentially bitmaps.
You can increase or decrease the quality in the Preferences dialog.
This is done under Edit, Preferences, where you can edit probes for resolution both in the viewport and at render time.
I have already set them to 1024, but the default is lower at 256.
Try different values to test viewport reflection quality.
However, I did mention earlier that reflection probes are a bit obsolete by today's standards.
This is because rendering engines have evolved quite a bit in the last few years.
Delete the reflection probe to go back to the SSR display.
In the Ambience panel, switch to Render mode.
Note how this project is set in real-time and uses the standard Global Illumination method.
Switch from Standard to Lumen.
Lumen is the newer rendering technology used in both Point Motion and Unreal Engine.
For all intents and purposes, you should rely on it as your go-to rendering method.
You can see the effect immediately. The reflections are high quality and very accurate.
What's more, the rendering in general is far superior. This can be mostly seen inside the building.
Note the effect of bouncing light and color bleed on the various surfaces.
Switching back and forth will give you a better appreciation of the differences between Lumen and the older standard method.
There is a third option. You could use path tracing, which acts as a traditional renderer giving you the best quality rendering available.
You can adjust the quality by using presets or by editing the rendering parameters.
Keep in mind that you need a high-end graphics card for path tracing to work.